[موسيقى]
الدعوه التي تلقيتها من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه والتعاون
المتنامي بيننا وبين المركز ما سمح بان
يصبح جزءا من نقاش واسع حول كيفيه
استجابتنا للازمات والنزاعات جرت العاده
ان تركز الاستجابه للازمه الانسانيه على
انقاذ حياه الناس والاسعاف السريع سواء
كان زلزالا او حربا وازمه انسانيه
والنزاعا ولكنها بصفه متزايده اصبحنا نعيش
في عالم يشهد تناميا مضطردا للازمات والتي
نسميها الازمات الحمائيه حيث تتطلب تدخلا
سريعا لحمايه الاهالي حيث هناك الان ما لا
يقل عن 100 مليون شخص عبر انحاء العالم هم
اما لاجئون او ناجحون داخل اراضي دواليهم
ولذلك فان برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائي
هو اليوم جزء من برنامج الامم المتحده
للاستجابه للازمات ومشاركتي الاخيره في
منتدى الرياض الدولي للعمل الانساني هو
شكل من الاعتراف باننا نعمل الان مع بعضنا
البعض بشكل اوثق من اي وقت مضت
[موسيقى]
لدينا الان برامج مشتركه للتعامل مع ازمات
ناشبه في عده دول ووقعنا خلال زياره
اتفقيتين اضافيتين لتعزيز
لان ما النتائج الحرب هناك اننا نشهد
اليوم ضحايا اكبر خارج ميدان القتال
والنزاع من اعدادهم على ما يدين المعارك
سواء بسبب الجوع او الاوبئه وعدم القدره
على حمايه الناس وهو من المتطلبات
الاساسيه لاي دوله ولذلك فان قدرتنا على
تدريب الناس على كيفيه التعامل والتجاوز
هذا الظرف الرهيب عبر حزمه خدمات نقدمها
وهي جزء من برنامج استجابه تنمويه طارئه
نتعاون فيها مع مركز الملك سلمان
[موسيقى]